You know,
I'm always curious about the,
let's say,
the practical implications of scientific
research both at a,
at a personal level,
familial level,
social level,
all of those things.
You know.
So I mean one of the things that I'm
planning to do in the near future is to
launch a website that will enable people
to assess themselves with what we've
developed.
A scale called the big five aspects
scale that breaks the big five down into
10 aspects,
each of which,
which provide some additional high
resolution and useful descriptions of
personality.
So you build to go there and find out
what your personality is like.
You'd be able to compare yourself to
other people who,
you know,
to find out where your similarities and
differences are.
But one of the things we've been
thinking about doing as well is putting
up on the same side or real Iq test.
Nicely validated.
Probably focusing on fluid intelligence
because it's a little bit less
linguistically complex to do so.
But maybe measuring verbal intelligence
and then showing people the strata of
occupations in which they're likely to
find maximal success.
Because you know,
from,
for me,
given that I know that,
that people vary in their cognitive
abilities tremendously and that that's
actually an important determinant of
their life outcome,
it seems to me.
So let's say someone tests out in an icu
of around a hundred and 50,
and so you can say,
look,
you know,
you're pretty damn smart.
You're,
you're up above 85 percent of the
general population.
You could,
you could probably do a pretty damn good
job as an undergraduate in university if
you're also disciplined,
right?
If you were conscientious,
he hit the books hard,
you're gonna,
you're gonna come out in the top core
tile of your class,
assuming that you're not at a
spectacularly successful,
a spectacularly selective university,
but you're going to have a much more
difficult time as a master's student and
phd level stuff is going to be.
You're going to be pushing your luck to,
to really master that.
But you know,
you could be,
here's a,
here's a domain of,
of,
uh,
what would you call it?
Industrial organizational activity where
you could really be in the top 10
percentile.
You know,
it's like,
so if you have an Iq of 115,
like you might make one bang up plumber
and you could have a spectacularly
successful career as a plumber and maybe
as a manager of other plumbers and all
of that and you know,
and I actually happened to be a real
emphasis,
he announced at one of the trade.
So I certainly don't think of that as
something that's a,
that's a low quality or low status
occupation in the least.
But we would,
we would like to tell people,
okay,
heres,
here's a,
here's an intellectual domain that's
probably too high for you to be
successful without working insane hours
to,
to close the gap because you can do that
within St.
work up to some,
some limited degree.
But it seems to me that the logical
thing to do at least in part is to give
people a sense of what their advantages
and limitations are and then say to
them,
okay,
well given that here's a place that you
could go where you could be optimally
successful.
And so,
you know,
that's Kinda my take from a policy
perspective,
let's say,
but like what have you thought about,
you know,
the massive diversity and intellectual
ability,
you mean what are the implications from
a policy perspective as far as you're
concerned?
Well,
I think vocational guidance is clearly
one.
I actually did some consulting and some
research for a nonprofit group called
the Johnson O'connor Foundation,
which is a vocational testing.
They're not that big on ge,
but they have their own battery of
tests.
They bring someone in and do a full day
of,
of cognitive tests.
And from that they give some advice
about what kinds of professions match
their cognitive strengths and
weaknesses.
And I actually did some brain imaging a
on their tests and it was very
interesting stuff.
Did you think they do because it's hard
to do the psychometrics properly with
regards to vocational guidance because
we don't really know.
We don't have a good handle on how to
classify jobs into their various
subtypes.
Like John Holland has done some good
work doing that,
but,
but there's so many jobs and it's hard
to figure out.
Well,
what makes two jobs the same or similar,
you know?
No,
I was at Hopkins when Hollen was there
in some of my friends were graduate
students work for him and I learned all
about that vocational testing.
That's very powerful.
And as you know,
it's,
that's more of his,
his scales have kind of morphed into
more personality.
White dementia.
Yeah.
Well that's it.
That's exactly the nexus that we want to
play out.
It's like okay,
because there is a reason.
I know people have been mapping Holland
Holland job categories onto the big five
and we have a fair bit of success,
you know,
and we're hoping that the
differentiation down to the 10 levels of
personality will provide even more
precision.
But,
but with more general policy let.
Okay.
So fine.
So reasonable vocational counseling.
That's a good idea.
When does it start?
Just starting junior high,
like do you do what the Europeans do and
start to track people into trades and,
and,
and higher education at that kind of
early age.
Your
opinion seemed to have had great success
with that.
So it's certainly Germans in particular.
Yeah.
So reasonable to look at.
But the problem in the United States,
there were so many problems with the way
we conceptualize education and the whole
idea of tracking.
I don't know how it is in Canada,
but in the United States,
this idea of tracking it has a very
negative balance.
Do it,
you know,
segregating the smart kids into one,
one a set of classes and the less smart
kids into others.
And then there's remedial education and
there's been a tendency,
a strong tendency,
the United States to feel that kids are
learning from each other.
So you don't want homogeneous groups
based on learning ability,
your want.
It's so funny because people say that
with regards to two,
let's say academic achievement,
but they play exactly the opposite.
Stumped when it comes to such things as
has childhood sports.
You know.
So if you look at football for example,
it's like,
well hey,
let's segregate like ability.
It's like you don't have the people who
stumble around on the field dropping the
ball all the time,
playing with the top end quarterbacks
and nobody thinks there's a problem with
that is they don't say,
well everyone learns from everyone else
in that situation.
So to me it speaks more of a refusal to
admit to the stark reality that there
are massive cognitive differences
between people and to try to actually
start to address that with some degree
of seriousness and the serious should be
something like,
okay,
well let's look at the bottom 15 percent
of the population cognitively speaking.
It's like what the hell can we do for
those people that's going to be useful?
And you know,
like the guy that I was telling you
about,
I was trying to think of some way that
he could find a,
a respectable and productive and
relatively stable position in society
that would be useful.
And I thought there was a couple of
things he could do.
Like one of the things he could have
done,
I think he could have been encouraged,
let's say,
to to collect trash in the downtown
areas like he could have been assigned a
city block and it could have been said
to him,
look,
your job is to keep this damn city block
clean.
Here's a bag,
here's the stick.
You get up in the morning,
you go do this.
It's like it makes everybody's life more
pleasant.
It's a valuable contribution.
It's something you could do with a
certain degree of pride and it and
there's a socially valuable end of it.
Now what happens in Toronto is that
people drive around these vacuum cleaner
machines on sidewalks and pick up the
scrap paper and all of that actually
turns out to be a very cognitively
demanding job because,
well,
you have to pay careful attention.
You can't run over people.
You have to have decent social skills
and you know it's complicated,
but it might be nice to see,
but we were not mature enough to have a
discussion like this.
As a society.
We might want to say is like,
okay,
well there's a group of people who
aren't going to be able to compete in
the,
in the cognitive workplace,
they're not going to do it and there's
actually lots of them and we're not
going to say they're lazy and we're not
going to say they're not looking for
work.
We're not going to say any of that.
We're going to say,
look,
we need to find occupations that have
public utility that aren't just make
work projects that people have.
That level of abstract capacity could
actually perform,
but I don't think we have the maturity
to have that conversation.
We don't have the economics.
And so I would go even a little to the
left of you and I would say there's
wrong with work programs,
you know,
to,
to allow people to work with dignity so
you have that option.
But you also had this interesting
experiment being proposed on the minimum
annual income.
Well,
that one worries me because see if
there's a couple of things about that
when it concerns me because,
you know,
so we're having a conversation here
where we're taking,
um,
differences in Iq seriously.
But the problem with the guaranteed
annual income issue,
I think one of the problems,
and I'm not denying its potential
utility,
it's something that I think that would
have to be experimentally determined,
you know,
and all of that.
And maybe it could replace a plethora of
less efficient social welfare programs.
But you know,
it isn't obvious to me.
It's obvious to me that there's a
substantial proportion of the
population.
And I would say it's probably five
percent that would destroy themselves
instantly if you gave them a guaranteed
annual income and they would do it
because they're very low in
conscientiousness,
for example.
And very impulsive.
And I've worked with many guys,
quite often x,
cocaine addicts who were often not all
that high on the end of the cognitive
distribution,
but very,
very low in conscientiousness in
impulsivity.
And those guys were absolutely fine as
long as they were flat broke.
But man,
I tell you as soon as they had money,
they were done.
It was like three days in the bar,
cocaine binge face down in a ditch and
then they were fine until they got money
again.
And so I don't.
The problem with the Guarente Dan annual
income solution is that man does not
live by bread alone.
Let's say in the.
If you have money and you have things to
do,
then you have a life.
But if you just have money,
you don't have a life.